mecheri danse avec les stars une
émission truqués ou pas on va la semaine
dernière dans tpm pesci leverdez avait
annoncé que les éliminations dendal ce
sont mises en scène et qu'arielle
dombasle ne ferait que quatre prime
et là je vous dis tout le monde sur la
toile sur twitter partout tout le monde
a dit gilles verdez est un héros parce
que gilles verdez avait dit ça et que et
que camil courait que je suis encore
dans camille et qu'arielle dombasle a
été éliminée si t'es ouf tout le monde y
des gens qui m'ont appelé regardez ce
qu'avait dit gilbert b en danse avec les
stars arielle dombasle a signé pour
quatre prime et après c'est elle qui
décidera si elle part ou si elle reste
alors c'est sûr donc ça doit les
brochettes et son port son dernier oui
oui oui mais voilà ça c'est un dernier
c'est elle qui décide je vais bien sûr
de ça d'accord j'ai bossé tout le week
end
alors les chéris ceux qui pensent que
des trucs et se met ici ceux qui pensent
ça n'est pas trop qu'ils se mettent là
c'est quand même fou qu'arielle dombasle
soit éliminé je vous le dis c'est
incroyable gilles verdez abidi alors on
va voir la prestation d'arielle dombasle
avec son danseur maxime dereymez la
danse et une rumba sur ma révérence de
véronique sanson elle est avant dernière
et elle a été éliminée alors que la
semaine d'avant elle était première donc
est quand même un petit peu ou fait
l'histoire regarde
[Musique]
son
[Applaudissements]
ils sont
non nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
être expliquée ou pas ici en tant que ça
n'est pas truquée on voit au moins ceux
qui prennent des risques
merci et nous oui si vous pensez que
c'est truqué jean-julien jeu très étonné
moi mettez-vous directement à côté moi
voilà vous dire que moi ni mon coin
franchement j'aurais pas m'aimer mais
lycéens senti maintenant au jeu je me
fie à ce que j'entends quand gilles
verdez soit c'est un devin et une petite
caravane et lille à venir mais les un
flic c'est juste que cgg famille et
parle un petit peu avec lui m'a raconté
un peu ses sources et jean ferrat voilà
pourquoi vous avez dit ça parce qu'elle
avait signé pour quatre princes à
l'aller en répétition de son film a
vraiment crystal palace vous qu'elle
pouvait pas rester vers là c'était 4 et
je m'en vais et moi ce que j'aimerais
avoir une à la faisons chez l'info d'un
journaliste très sérieux qui m'ont
envoyé serré je peux pas dire qui c'est
mais qui m'a dit elle est actuellement
sur son film elle devait partir de danse
avec les stars obligatoirement samedi et
c'est un journée vraiment qui dit très
peu de bêtises je vous le dis donc
gilles vous aviez la mairie on prend les
gens pour des gogos parce qu'on fait
voter les gens mais en fait tout est
écrit à l'avancé tout est scénarisé
c'est pour ça qu'on a tous absents
bachiri dit la vérité lors maison vous
pouvez pas savoir qui ont si c'est
truqué ou pas nous on veut pas savoir où
on est dans l'aventuré en ville aventure
on se sent c'est parce qu'à d'un contrat
d'arielle dombasle ça se passe entre
avocats honnêtement on sait pas mais est
ce que les contrats ils sont très
travaillés ça veut dire que vous pouvez
dire moi je peux rester que deux
semaines attention aussi aux nettement
nous on n'a pas pu le faire quand on a
même dit sur internet que j'avais
négocié ma sortie pour pouvoir faire les
terriens du dimanche le jeudi et non
j'aime beaucoup de séries mais j'étais
là poursuivre l'aventuré
non parce que ça n'est pas truquée non
mais en vérité gilts oublie tout
simplement qu'il ya un huissier de
justice
non mais c'est un mec a servi à amiens
paris où son jeu suivant alors blessé
contacté vu c'est du oui alors j'ai le
oui s'affala des malades et la
production alors moi je savais pas
vraiment répondu non mais c'est un faux
débat les u6 on sait qu'on en fait ce
qu'on veut et ça m
bravo mais non c'est parce qu'il vient
de leur nom
non c'est parce que je dis on en fera
sur mac on en fait pas ce qu'on veut tu
vas pas là c'est con c'est
qu'effectivement le procès des deux
hommes forts on peut l'arrêter plus ou
moins tôt donc je vais pas sur un
argument le l'huissier en revanche déjà
il avait été dit aussi par le même
gilles que le couple eux
seulement voilà vincent et toi vous
seriez sortie parce que tf1 ne pas faire
la promo de ses huit bons mais c est
tout le temps récent film qui sort
franchement je dis pas ça parce que
j'aime beaucoup enfin absatou
normalement il doit rester les gens
l'adorent
franchement les ailes très bien je suis
prouvée comme fer pour la f1 parce que
caps à tout-va sport à tf1 ni vraiment
ses buts mais autres arguments sinon
comment expliquer sinon rien on a
beaucoup de problèmes avec tf1 vous le
savez et 6 et 8 aux délires peur à tf1
il serait plus sympa avec nous l'année
précédente contre on était payé le plus
cher qu une plus gros cachet
malheureusement sont souvent sorti au
début du conflit winter je pense à
estelle halliday
voilà quel était l'intérêt de l'épée et
3 tonnes pour qu'il marque halal à la
semaine dernière il y avait il ya aussi
le bonus de points qui a été donné la
semaine dernière à arielle dombasle pour
qu'elle reste et cette semaine
bizarrement elle termine ce qu'ils
avaient peur comme la fois d'avant déjà
la première émission elle était dernière
vincent cerutti n'aurait jamais dû
sortir
il avait peur qu'elle soit viré comme
elle avait signé pour 4 elle ne pouvait
pas sortir on peut pas dire ce qu'il
pense que c'est pas truqué là vous allez
vas-y tu sais pas ce que vous prenez au
cox un concours de danse aoc depuis la
première édition c'est pas un gros comme
il est juste une émission de télévision
a parlé mais les vrais concours comme
top chef ou comme le goût meilleurs
pâtissiers il n'y a pas le public c'est
kéké c'est juste le jouet qui alors
qu'elle avait connu le pull maître du
public ça fait déjà un peu d'oseille et
doit ça permet de déplacer le curseur
quand on veut fo sont lassés des réseaux
histoire qu'on veut raconter on confirme
instant à proville
d'ailleurs mon père n'en verront alors
quel intérêt le même thème l'inconnu en
font en fait pas de glace et les moins
bons élèves et la belle histoire d'amour
on peut pas dire ici tout est ce vrai
contrat on peut pas dire ici tout et son
contraire on n'a pas arrêté de dire ici
que justement c'était pas une émission
de danse qui fait qu'à éliminer à la
notoriété
les plus les moins connus fin de moules
et moins
willem qui avait une des mois grosse fan
base partait en premier arielle dombasle
j'imagine qu'elle n'a pas une énorme fan
base et que donc ils se sont pas
mobilisés pour arrêter les jurys ils
l'ont dit ils ont cédé à ben dernière
arrêté bien naïve et patoche le sais
mais bon on va juste regarder souffler
la prestation d'apps à tout pour se
faire soi même voilà la dernière
prestation des atouts parce que ça nous
ait trouvé formidable
merci c'est superbe pour placido ligne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en seconde on va laisser parler
isabelle vernant ou dix secondes parce
que je veux après terminé je veux avoir
l'avis de réunion et l'avis d'accord moi
je parlais je m'en fiche profil
lorsqu'on en vaut certainement
[Applaudissements]
à votre avis que ces trucs on va
regarder la vie du public
regardez l'avis du public les ché oui